in just a couple of hours president joe  biden expected to unveil a six-point  plan to beat the uptick of the delta  variant in addition to increasing  vaccination rates the plan includes more  protections for vaccinated americans  increased testing and masking  requirements improving care for people  who have the virus protecting the  economic recovery as well as keeping  schools safely open we know that  increasing vaccinations will stop the  spread of the pandemic will get the  pandemic under control will return  people to normal life that's what our  objective is president biden not  expected to issue a mandate for all  americans to be vaccinated but the white  house is encouraging businesses and  local governments to take that extra  step